a function f of x is plotted below
highlighted an interval where f prime of
x or the first derivative of f with
respect to x is greater than zero
so if our derivative f prime of x is
greater than zero that means that the
slope of the tangent line is positive
that means that the function must be
increasing whenever this is true so
where is a function increasing so over
here we see that as x increases as x
increases our function is going to
smaller and smaller values so our
function is decreasing this entire place
then it's it's decreasing at slower and
slower rates all the way to the point
right over here where the function the
slope of the tangent line is flat and
then the function starts increasing it
starts increasing it faster and faster
and faster rates so we could put this
blue area anywhere from here to anywhere
in this region here where the function
itself is increasing notice the function
could even be negative but the function
is increasing so even this would be a
valid place that would be a valid place
anywhere where the functions rate of the
when x increases the function is
actually getting larger so let's check
our answer and let's do a couple more of
these
a function f of x is plotted below
highlighted interval where f of x is
greater than zero so f of x should be
sitting in the first or second quadrant
right over here needs to be greater than
zero and f prime of x is less than zero
so
f prime of x less than zero means that
the function is decreasing the slope of
the tangent line is negative so let's
think about it the two areas where f of
x is greater than zero
are this interval right over here
and
this interval right over here but we
also care about the function decreasing
this won't be valid because the function
is increasing here it's increasing at
slower and slower rates but it is
increasing the function is going up as x
goes up
if we go over here the function is
decreasing as x increases so this seems
to meet our constraints this this area
right over here won't because the
function is positive but it's also
increasing so here the derivative is
positive
here the derivative is positive here the
derivative is negative so the function
itself is positive but the slope of the
tangent line is negative it's decreasing
as x increases
let's do one more
a function f is plotted below highlight
interval where f of x is greater than
zero and f prime of x is less than zero
so the same exact idea where are we
positive but our function is actually
decreasing so it's positive here but we
can't pick that it's positive here but
we can't pick that the function is
decreasing here
but the function isn't positive there
the derivative is negative but the
function isn't positive so we that one
made it make it so this is the only
region that we can kind of throw it in
and we got it right again